John chyme covers the Washington
Redskins for the mothership kind enough
to join us this morning
John you have to come up with new
business cards there's a lot of things
to come up with here it's gonna be very
weird because you go for I've covered
this team for a long time and so people
ask you what do you do I cover the I
write about the Washington Redskins now
it's going to be like well what do you
play about the Washington who yeah so
it's it's going to be very very
different and take some getting used to
for a lot of people why now well I think
you can go back to the George Floyd
death while in police custody and go and
start from there because we've all known
for a while that there was pressure on
this team to change the name for a while
and it wasn't really going anywhere the
pattern in the past was weather the
storm get to the quiet part and just you
know survived the controversy well after
that point we all saw what was happening
in society and that was the the protests
the riots statues coming down you know
very flags the other Confederate flag
I'm noting flow anymore at NASCAR and
all that so I think that led to sponsor
or two groups feeling like there was a
window open of opportunity that had
never existed before and then they
started going after sponsors and once
you start doing that and as you know
that's when you get things done I think
that's been the difference here when it
came out that and we could done a story
about the letter that investors and
shareholders sent to PepsiCo Nike FedEx
when that came out I talked to somebody
who had worked for this place for a
while knew the situation well his
response was holy crap this is different
yeah it feels different and by all
accounts the reports are that they're
gonna change the the name this morning
what are the options that you've heard
it and I'll give you my logic of what I
think it's going to be well I think the
one that kind of jumps out right away is
warriors only because Dan Snyder used to
when when he first bought the the
Redskins he also bought the rights to an
Arena Football League franchise team if
they came to Washington he when then
wanted to trade
mark the name warriors even had some
logos design I think it was a spear on
the helm and all that so if the name has
changed quickly that to me would be the
leader in the clubhouse now as far as
like I know that there are some you know
in Ron Rivera said I think others there
I know that there's some other names
they might like that's the only one that
I think I know for sure would be an
option I think what if you talked to
fans the name that they jumped on lately
his red wolves and I have to get a
little Twitter poll last a couple days
ago I think it was like almost 17,000
votes and more than 40% wanted red walls
so I think red tails was a name that was
discussed I don't know that they go in
that direction one of the things I think
that was important to them was initially
wanted to maintain some connection to
Native Americans but also the military
and maybe war that's why I keep leaning
toward warriors I don't know that for
sure but that's Riley I thought that
something that started with an R
therefore you could keep the script bar
that the Redskins have and keep a little
bit of that tradition but red tails or
renegades or red wolves would be where I
would lean what do you think of that
logic yeah and I think that's I think
there's some definite logic there
because one of the things that they also
want to do is maintain some traditions I
was told that the plan is now is to keep
the burgundy and gold colors big part in
tradition another part is the marching
band and then also they love the phrase
H the fans love the phrase HT t are hail
to the Redskins so you can maintain some
of that and and I think you can get that
so yeah that's I can see that as well I
think warriors again I still need toward
that but I think your logic is correct
and then you could come up with the logo
that has a script R on the helmet yeah
and if you're a fan tuning in and you
don't know the name has changed maybe
you can forget for a minute if you who
is that important to you that it still
is still the same franchise you're
rooting for
how does this go wrong I've covered the
scene for a while I think the way to go
wrong is if you rush into a branding
situation with the logo I don't think
you want to rush into that when I've
talked to people about that that process
takes a long time I think
that's the important thing to get right
here is what is that logo going to be
like don't rush it there has a feel of a
fire am ready to this in part because of
the way this is all unfolded this isn't
something that going into the offseason
Dan Schneider had a plan on doing it was
kind of forced upon him for whatever
reason because like we talked about
earlier so I think if you rush it that's
where you can get into trouble this is a
monumental thing and you know like how
sports fans are with these teams and you
also know that in 15-20 years
whatever you decide now is what people
will identify with so take your time and
get it right yeah my whole thought with
this is it's always the bottom line it's
about money even the memo they sent out
starts with thanking you know sponsors
fans community in that order John and
then I think of this as Daniel Snyder
can still say to his loyal fan base I
tried but I couldn't they wouldn't allow
me to keep it and you get this whole
revenue stream of new memory I'm
merchandise here so I think Daniel
Snyder is going to do well with this you
know go kicking and screaming sort of
but also hey now all of a sudden I got a
whole new revenue stream that I never
thought I was going to be getting yeah
and I think that's what people have long
been trying to tell him those who wanted
to change years ago that you can benefit
financially from this now obviously
there's going to be a cost involved
you're gonna have to change changing all
the signage the merchandise everything
is going to be probably more than ten
million dollars so there's gonna be a
cost but you know you're gonna get fans
like I've heard from fans to say I want
for this team again I think it's a small
percentage but that's looping that group
exists I also wonder Dan to who jumps on
board with this because there are a lot
of people in this in the Washington area
in the last few years they haven't
exactly been flocking to games here
because a team it's not about the name
it's about the team not being good maybe
with the new name comes some new energy
for some people who were maybe not on
the board with it before so I think that
that there is a potential you may have
people who say hey because they changed
it now I'm gonna support him I'll go out
and buy the gear and that's where I go
back to the logo and the
Brandee if you get that right you really
cash in in that regard
John thanks for joining us I know it's a
busy time for you we appreciate it hope
you're well my pleasure thanks for
having me that's John chyme he covers
the Washington whoever for the
mothership